hi guys I have a short video I'm gonna
talk about ginger lemon water and in a
minute fasting and why this would be a
very good thing to do now first of all
ginger has a ton of amazing properties
number one it has a like 115 known
antioxidants and I'm talking about
phytonutrients which have a variety of
properties anti-inflammatory properties
anti-cancer benefits to help if you're
nauseous especially if you're pregnant
morning sickness great for gas also
motion sickness okay so you could take
ginger for that and then the biggest
benefit is the blood sugar it has the
potential to decrease insulin and I mean
people have been using ginger for pride
thousands of years so anything that's
been around that long has stood the test
of time
so gingers a really proven thing over
the years okay so why do you want to add
a lemon because when you're doing
fasting and you're doing ketosis there's
a potential risk of kidney stones
so lemon has sit rates and sit rates
combined with oxalates and that way it
can decrease your risk of getting
calcium oxalate stones and of course
lemon has a lot of vitamin C as well
okay so this is what you do 1/4 a cup of
ginger or one ounce of ginger you can
get it in a liquid already one lemon and
12 ounces water so I recommend that you
take about 1/4 cup of ginger and you can
shred it let it soak in the water for
about 30 to 60 minutes okay it doesn't
have to be warm it could be cold water
and then what you do is you get a
cheesecloth and you can actually then
strain all the fiber let the juice go
through the cheesecloth and then once
you have this mixture this water with
ginger then what you do is you take a
lemon I like the lemon press is where
you can actually squeeze the entire
lemon so you can get the maximum amount
of juice from that lemon and then you
already have the water in there because
you've already measured now you have
this mixture of lemon and ginger water
and you want to drink that when you're
fasting on an empty stomach it's not
going to break a fast it's going to help
you increase the fast because of what it
does for your blood Sugar's it decreases
insulin and that you're also gonna have
other benefits as well you're going to
decrease cholesterol decrease blood
pressure potentially but the main thing
is you're going to decrease your hunger
you're going to find you just not hungry
all right guys there you have it a
simple remedy using ginger and lemon
water so if you're enjoying this content
go ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it